coming up on season five of red table
talk
[Music]
please jada pinkett smith makes her
return to the red table following the
oscars slap heard around the globe
oh wow red table talk is returning to
facebook watch with new episodes
starting on wednesday and in a teaser
for the new season it looks like jada
her daughter willow smith and her mom
adrian benfield norris will sit down
with kim basinger i wouldn't leave the
house i would no longer go to dinner i
had to relearn to drive and kim's
daughter with alec baldwin ireland
baldwin i have been in physical abusive
relationships i have been an emotional
verbal very gas-lit manipulative
relationships i've been through a lot of
different kinds of abuse tinder swindler
victim eileen charlotte he pretended to
be the son of a diamond mogul he
defrauded me for over 100 000 dollars he
left me with nothing anna delvey's
former bestie rachel williams i met anna
in 2016. i finally ended up going to the
police janelle monae and more my dad had
gotten on crack cocaine i was dealing
with real rejection abandonment issues
it takes practice to have those
difficult conversations with kindness
and consideration
and it's just something that we have to
continue to practice because if we don't
talk about it
we're not going to get to the other side
the more that we can bring these
difficult subjects to light and talk
about it the more we can purify these
subjects and bring them into something
new but one difficult conversation they
don't appear to have
addressing the moment jada's husband
will smith smacked chris rock across the
face live on air at the 2022 academy
awards
oh wow of course the whole thing started
after chris made a joke about the oscar
winner's wife following the incident
will resigned from the academy before
the board of governors decided to ban
the king richard starr from all academy
events for 10 years calling his behavior
quote unacceptable and harmful the
53-year-old actor responded to the
ruling in a statement to e.t writing
quote i accept and respect the academy's
decision and jada she made her first
public appearance following the incident
at an event for shonda rhimes new
performing arts center flashing a peace
sign for the photographers
how are you doing good good billy porter
was also there and gave his two cents on
the altercation as a black queer man who
has been dragged through the mud for not
being masculine enough
in this world
you know
being called the cause of the
emasculation of the black man because i
decide to play with feminine silhouettes
in my clothing
it's really disheartening
that the version of masculinity shows up
like that
it's upsetting
it's upsetting and i will be
the black queen
that i am
because if that is the representation of
what masculinity is supposed to be i
don't need it looks like fans will just
have to wait to see if jada brings the
oscar slap to the red table but one
thing's for sure these ladies don't shy
away from tough topics something they've
opened up to e.t about in the past but
what is it about this table when people
come and sit here what's that magic
sauce that just makes people say
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna spill
it we just always wanna have just real
conversations and so i think it's um
we're in the conversation with you right
yeah we're we're we're we're sharing our
stories we're sharing our experiences
and it's just about commun you know
we're just communing together like when
they see us be vulnerable then they're
like oh okay it's it's okay to be
vulnerable it's a safe space for
vulnerability
[Music]